you
alrighty hi this is Jeff clima for new
media rockstars i'm sitting here with
internet sensation taryn southern whose
first full-length album just dropped how
you doing today Taryn I'm so good how
are you I'm doing excellent i'm the one
who asks the questions though you just
sit back an answer now just give me a
hard time i'm sorry i suppose to by
heart so i can't help it okay there you
go yeah you're naturally inquisitive all
right now for the record is Taryn
southern your real name yes it's still
my real name everyone asked me this it's
so funny do you yeah my mom just picked
like the most cheesy after II name for a
kid but it's all real yeah it's kind of
got that like I mean did you get teased
about having kind of a pornstar ish name
or I didn't use a poor Victor name I
better be the perfect name for a country
singer oh well that's good no that is
that is nice of course you see where my
mind's at verses where your minds at so
that's good to know so all right are you
started this off on the right but oh
well now to be fair you started it by
calling your album on my face okay yes
Matt now i get i get the i get the
double entendre dirty side but what do
you tell say normal media reporters that
on my face is in reference to I don't
tell normal media reporters it's in
reference to anything other than know to
be honest my viewers on YouTube chose
the name there was like five possible
album titles that were all suggested by
viewers and then they voted for that one
for obvious reasons but what I think is
really funny about it is every time I
close out a video most the time and when
I close out a video I always tell people
to subscribe right here on my face and
then I put up annotation link on my face
so I always say that so it actually is
um totally all about the fact that like
every time I make a video this this the
shameless self-promotion always comes in
the form of an annotation link on my
face so it's it's a double entendre for
shameless self-promotion now she and i
would have felt bad at that that'd been
the total case those two ice creams tell
me everything so I'm not too worried too
but I still had to make an album cover
you know well of course of course you
got it you gotta move via gonna move the
tunes now is is on my face is it
completely download based or is their
physical CDs of it or there are physical
CD of cds of it and i actually would
love for people to buy them physically
because i spent a lot of time the cover
and back cover and the inside cover was
designed by us by fans i did this whole
contest for fans to sign inside covers
and then I got reviews from from
different celebrities on the album that
are all part of the part of the physical
album you can get the physical album on
cdbaby.com and it will be available on
Amazon any time now I don't understand
the delay i am not in the music world I
don't get it but apparently it takes a
long time to get physical album listings
up online but i will show you really
quick I have to do this I'm gonna go
grab this I got this in the mail today
I'm so excited its my special on my face
commemoration plaque so this is actually
the cover designed by the fan anyway
that is pretty badass I'll give you that
like pets that's as far as cool things
that have like that's one of the cooler
ones yeah so nicely done all right well
you have you have kind of a very out
their online presence so we're gonna do
kind of a very out-there interview if
that's okay I'm down I'm always down I
like it okay now so on the scale from
one to ten where does a good poop fall a
good poop fall yeah I mean definitely
falls in the toilet you wouldn't want it
you wouldn't want to falling on the
floor no no I'm let's say okay let me
rephrase that then haha I'm glad that
you know where it goes that's that's
good that's step number one so we've
achieved that much like going to the
bathroom like taking a good dump or
going having a good bathroom experience
where does that go for you on the one to
ten like as far as just pleasurable
experiences in life yes 10 baby okay
good and that's on there that's kind of
what I was expecting but yeah
again it's good it's good to brush up on
the basics and emotional release yeah
now what is what is the response been
from some of the viewers the reviewers
rather from four on my face so far
really good you know you didn't even I
didn't even think about this when I put
up the album the day that I uploaded
everything I was like oh people
actually might think my music sucks
because I've always been so concerned
with just trying to make like silly
songs and then the videos for them I
didn't think about the fact that you're
putting it on itunes and people might
hate the music hopefully I get a little
bit of slack because it's a comedy album
it's not a real album but so far the
reviews have all been been really really
positive so that makes me happy that is
good now do you I mean do you have like
in addition to all the silly fun songs
you write do you also have a serious
side that creates serious tunes and is
that something won't be seeing yes I
actually do have a couple of songs that
i'll be putting out an EP for after the
comedy album that are serious tracks and
I say serious because they're not
they're not comedy but I think they
still fall in the world of like Katy
Perry type pop you know they're there
poppy and they're fun and they're like a
little bit wacky whether or not they're
not about vaginas okay okay well that I
mean that's both a good and a bad thing
I suppose see what people think of that
it's interesting has I for a long time I
always thought people wouldn't want to
hear mixing about serious stuff because
they come to my youtube channel to watch
comedy videos in my first video I just
released its like third of the comments
or like why are you wasting your time
singing about silly stuff you should be
singing about serious stuff so hopefully
people will like it when I when I put
out a couple serious drives yeah exactly
now what but just I mean since you
brought it up uh you have a song called
what is it no it's something vagina it's
remarkable vagina markable vagina is
this an autobiographical song or is this
no no I think a lot of people are very
confused about where the inspiration
came from the song does seem a little
bit random mm-hmm but it's based on that
troops it's not even based on it is the
musical retelling of a totally true
story last year I stumbled excuse me
stumbled upon a new york magazine
article called the chick with the
remarkable vagina an article in New York
magazine and is about a girl he was
smuggling heroin amongst other things in
her vagina and was arrested and sent to
jail for it and I just thought it was
such a funny article headline that I was
like this deserves a song what would I
and I started thinking what would I you
know put in my vagina my vagina was
remarkable and this is where the song
was born from so no it did not actually
come out of my crazy head it it was it
was born and bred out of a real hard
news article okay well that's good i was
gonna be concerned about the amount of
drugs yet up there so my vanity is what
your yeah yeah maybe a little bit but
now making your sanity also another good
segue is perfect here another of your
songs is internet stalker yes II have
you actually had one have I hadn't and I
mean cuz the song is about how I'm
stalking someone else online I've
definitely had a couple of internet
stalkers that were a little bit freaky
but I think all of us it's just some
degree can relate to the song on a small
level for some people and and I
grandiose level for others but the idea
being that like if you have a crush on
someone you like someone it's really
easy to know everything that they're
doing at all times just by logging into
you know that you're their accounts and
always checking up on them that way
however it can be taken to an extreme
and yes I've had a couple of creepy
creepy internet stalkers okay well
although i'll have to change my screen
name then no I'm just treating I'm sorry
uh alright funnier word penis or farts
are fresher okay ours isn't everything
funny about her a good fart joke and
nothing funny about a bad penis joke oh
wow alright if you had to choose between
acting and singing which way do you
think you'd go now oh gosh uh suppose
singing I think is more fun i think i
don't know i don't like performing live
though so maybe acting I don't know see
I can't even answer a question that's
fine no that was good that was another
one of those that I'm glad that you
don't have an answer so no jakey you are
yeah yeah this is one of those sneaky
interviews all right now how much has
say like the lonely island and influence
on your work Everything Everything
Everything the first video I ever saw
his dick in a box I thought it was so
funny I was like actually wasn't the
first video from them but it you know
one of the first ones that I just fell
in love with and now I know everything
one of their songs my heart and I think
that was a big reason when i started
making musical comedy videos was because
of Andy Samberg Andy good to know all
right so--okay so if you could kind of
have that that same career trajectory
obviously that's the way to go up yeah I
would really like to have the budgets
that they have for my music videos too
but we can't have it all can we exactly
right how are the music video is going
by the way you're filming one for each
song yeah yeah it's crazy um my first
one just went up yesterday remarkable
vagina I've got my next one I think I
started coming out next week then my
song guys then google that so I
have a whole succession of videos I'm a
little bit behind right now I'm shooting
which makes me a bit nervous because I'm
going on tour in late November but um
because I but it's yeah it's all working
out I love making these videos it's so
it's my favorite thing in the world to
do partly because you don't worry about
sound thanks but I'm not just shooting
the music videos I've got a
corresponding series going up for alloy
digital um and a column on their
property crushable that if that is that
directly relates to my music videos and
then I have another eight-part series
for official comedies premium youtube
channel and it's essentially behind the
scenes bloopers look at making of my
videos it's called deep inside another
double entendre so all in all i'm making
8 24 8 16 24 videos 24 videos over eight
weeks which is a lot so I don't sleep a
lot yeah that's so that's that's
impressively busy I'll give you that so
you want all the told panic attack oh is
that is I right you gotta sit the night
constant flux if you're not achieving
your freaking out ok I can get behind
that for sure that and final cut
rendering Oh take you forever just want
to do that yeah oh I can imagine okay
well good all right well now your humor
is so determinedly vulgar right
that comes off almost like almost
defensive you know what I mean so look
sorry saying such sweet words oh well
thank you maybe my the you what we when
you take defensive I'm just asking it's
a it's not as loaded to the question as
we think I'm just saying I don't by the
way you can say anything well I don't
feel loaded I just okay cuz there's
gonna be some nasty questions coming
laters now I'm just kidding I'm hahaha
but I'm just asking I mean are you
really kind of a very private person I
mean aside from what your your public
persona seems to be yeah i think so i
think um by weight I don't even really
think I'm I'm funny like I never I've
never thought of myself as a comedian
but I've always thought of myself as a
group fall and when I'm with my closest
girlfriends and we're drinking wine and
we're having a slumber party the stuff
that comes out of our mouth is just lewd
and crude and the thing is I don't think
there's really much difference between
that and any girl out there I think
everyone has their you know their inner
in your inner comedian that comes out
with their best friends I think what you
see on line is is probably closer to
that girl who's like three margaritas
into a girls night um but typically
around most people and just everyday
life and I think I'm actually more more
reserved and would probably be thought
of as much more conservative than you
would see in my videos okay so I mean it
but then so for your video sake of the
bull Gators say it's more of a it's
about girls being real more than it is
they like trying to stand out in a niche
market you know I wouldn't I don't think
it's this persona I do think I do think
you have to be consistent with your
message online and my message might
change I mean pakka five like a baby in
two years I might be like oh my gosh I
don't want to put any of those videos
out online like if I have a kid um your
priorities change but it's definitely me
it's not a persona but you're just
seeing one side of me you're seeing like
one very specific side of Terran and
you're not seeing like the shy stage
fright conservative version of that
I'm always horrified when explosion when
I was I have a boyfriend now but when I
was like going out and dating and it was
like people would say that they see my
videos and they'd be watching my video
some of the more embarrassing with I'd
be horrified I'm like I don't want this
guy to know this information about me I
thought only like YouTube viewers watch
it I forget it like other people I might
meet in real life that I interact with
see the videos and for some reason I
feel very uncomfortable so I feel like
now that their privy to this like one
side of me that I don't want them to
like take that at all all that I am just
your pretty rotten raunchy girl haha you
play it all it's all very nice balance
their good work on you but uh yeah how
do you how do your parents feel about
that they were just so completely used
to it because I see you said you had a
lot of brothers in one of your
interviews I believe it no I don't know
any brothers no brothers oh I'm probably
reading somebody else maybe I have a lot
of dude friends Oh a lot of prince who
knows maybe maybe I lied in the
interview maybe I just following thing
I'd brothers I have a younger sister my
parents bless their hearts they are so
supportive and encouraging no matter
what I do but I would be lying if I said
that they probably were not embarrassed
by my videos I'm sure that they I'm sure
my mom like starts watching it and it's
just like oh why why and then like turns
it off I'm positive okay they're they're
very supportive they don't ever say you
know sometime I don't make comments like
did you have to make a video about that
i'ma catch mom I did I felt I felt this
deep calling inside my heart to make a
video about this i'm sorry but they get
it okay now how rough was it to be cut
on American Idol was that a pretty
brutal one at the time it was the most
devastating moment of my life um I
couldn't find I was so upset because I
don't know if you saw the clip in my
last youtube video is a promo for my
album and I used a clip from American
Idol and I was trying to find a clip
where I'm up on stage and crying and
Ryan Seacrest is like patting me on the
back and telling me it's gonna be okay
and Simon is telling me that I'm never
going to be a star I wanted to use that
so bad and I couldn't find it so I used
a different clip from the show but it
was them yeah it was devastating like
that
moment was the one moment that defined
like I think the next ten years of my
life which was like I'd ever wanted to
do or aging myself like eight years of
my life I didn't want to be an
entertainer anymore so that's why I went
back to college and got my anthropology
degree was because of that experience um
but I'm now back it's just now I'm
battling crazy stage fright because of
Simon but it was it was for ya laughs at
it though but ok so well now you're kind
of I mean you really kind of coming into
your own on your own terms so you're not
chew or mean by the american idol thing
so if you rip if you ran across Simon
Cowell what do you say to him now I did
I where I worked with Simon and Paula on
The X Factor last fall I was a
correspondent on the show um and so I
was I was on the lot with him every
single week working with him every
single week and I thought it was
hilarious it's like everything comes
full circle I think they're great I
think that they're right most of the
time I think they were right in my
instance I was a 17 year old girl that
had no experience on stage and I wasn't
ready for that kind of platform and I
wasn't I just didn't have the the I
didn't have the chops at the time and so
I found my own little way in ok see you
have you have the chops now i don't know
i don't think i have the chops now I
wouldn't hurt no I would never go into a
live live live performing competition
show I just I don't have the chops I
have the worst nerves on the planet i
did i did what's trending Shira Lazar is
live show a couple of days ago and I
mean like I'm literally off pitch on
every other note because I just get so
nervous I'm fine singing at a karaoke
bar in front of friends I'm fine singing
in a recording studio but when I go when
I know I'm live and I know I can't do it
over again I think that American Idol
experience that comes back to haunt me
and I just I die like clinch up and I
have a hard time just sounding as good
as I i think they normally would or
remembering lyrics or any of those
things I don't know what why I was
cursed with this but I was so I just
have to be okay with it haha yeah I
believe you have a performance coming up
at the viper room or is that true or is
that you i have a
big album release party November first
I'm going to be performing I don't know
like seven or eight tracks off the album
I will probably want to throw up on
stage and it's the first time I'm
inviting everyone to be there with me so
I'm just hoping everyone gets wasted and
claps and then it becomes a fun sort of
way for me to get over my stage fright
whatever with all my friends there and
Viper Room is very kind to be giving me
this night so all right well very good
well I'll tell you what new meteor rock
stars wishes you the best of luck so
thank you for taking the time to sit
down with us thank you guys oh I'm i
wanna i loved the interview that you did
um I don't know like six months ago
there was some time ago yeah for sure so
but thank you very much again for
sitting down with us you're a sweetheart
and we can't wait to see what you do
next all right it's called I think I
farted that's what I do next okay oh
good work you film us all right well I
will talk to you at some point good luck
and have a good day huh bye you two
buh-bye
you